宮司エビング l 1 my name is 正方はファミリア
mater ずオール o
トゥデイアン going to ツェリ甘いストーリー
プラン次は音釣井ニャー9
あなたはあなたの5本を中に何分の木を持っていますか
私はそうですねインターネットの大きい
旅行の木ピア論抜き
それから excel あーずというエクセルで踊ってデザインをする期
それから感動のピその the たくさんの木を持っていますけれども今日は空がただ
英語の木についてお話をさせていただきます
私はここできっと言っているのは私の心の中にちょっと芽生えている
小さな
肺がんですねこれを私が育てて
で段々大きくしてそのうちに剥がし下に実がなって
大きな木になるそれをに対する
と言うんでしょうかねまあそれは未来に対する期待というか希望というかもしかすると
夢かもしれません
でも私はそれを育てることにとてもお楽しみを感じています
今もそうです
でそれに私はぷドボン時はとても好奇心の旺盛な子供でした
いろいろな新しいことに興味を持っていたのですけれども
特に
外国っていうことところに対して
人一倍関心を持ち憧れを持っていました
そんな私が40代の半ばになった高でしょうか
まあ日本がそれまでは普通の人が海外に渡航することは許されていなかったんです
けれども私たち普通の人も旅行に行っていいっていうことになったんです
ギャッと思って私は
そうですね限られた休暇を
やりくりしてヨーロッパやお世話ね家に一人で旅をしてもありました
もちろんそれは感動の毎日でした
そんなある時
ミュウヘンで知り合ったアメリカ人の牧師さんが
アントワ
ニュアメリカてるも見たほうがいいそうだ
ほなしかったの私の牧師館に行きなさいそして
浴び字ステーをしてそっからアメリカを見なさいと言われてアメリカに行きました
皆さんどうでも良くして下さったんですけども私は
とにかく方ほど目語しか喋れないのでもっともっと色々交流しただったらにとても不
満足でした
というのは私の指示たようなことはなかなか英語で表現できなかったんです
それは
ホテル予約をするというときに使うような英語では済ませなかったら
ん
もっと英語の勉強したいその時そう思えました
そして私は旅行するとまぁ皆さんと同じように楽しい
美しい風景を楽しんだり真っ白立たず前を見て感心したですそれ以上にそこに住んで
いるさあどんな人かどんな人かした塗装
想像してしまうのです
そこにコーヒーを飲んでいらっしゃる方は私と同年代度はあの人は戦時中
どんな症状自体を送ったのか車
その大きな牧場のオーナーは今何を考えていらっしゃるのかしら
そんなことが次から次へと浮かんでくるんでした
しかし私にとってのエゴへの道はとっても遠いのでしたといいますのは
私私が戦争中そうな
皆さんが想像を少ないような時代だったんですね
えっあの戦争中は英語を使うことは禁止されてたんです
ですから野球の審判もですねバンス52ボールなった
叱られるんです
よし1本ダメ日本って言わなければならなかった
そんな時代だったんですですからなかなか英語とは縁がなかった
高校卒業してから務めた原稿でも海外とは関係のない仕事を続けていました
仕事をリザイアして介護も終わってやっと少し自分の事業が戻る時私はもう70になっ
ていましただめだわもうこんな年になったらとてもダメ
だってどんどん
記憶力が低下していくでしょ語学が一番ダメをね
何と言って諦めかけていました
女だけまったくどういうわけか
卓球お話ししてられたあのてゼックスの2014にスピーカーとして出させていただい
たんです
一体スピーカーって上手もの打者とても心ボスがあったんですけれども
形の方の温かいサポートとそれから観客の方の拍手とそれ
生
選んで私はなぜとか終わりまでこぎつけさん
ほっとしました
だからへ保温学んでいきたいということはまたそこでも出てきました
そんだけ考えたんです
だけど
私はそんなエクセルって言うに excel なぁと考えたと言うな
エクスのに刀 c am 女性のために少し
女性像 f せるを近づけるために考えてのエクセルはそれだったら
a 方だって深夜にもうちょっと近づける
何かがあるんじゃないか車と思って考えていた
んですねシニアはシニアねのやり方がそうしたらその母の介護をした時のことを
思い出しました
もちろん年相応に競技力は低下していきますけれども昔から知っていた言葉というのは
意外と覚えてんですね
たとえそれがカタカナもでも外来語でも雄鶏だったんです
ん
考えてみたら私に普段使っている言葉にもカタカナもや
外 daigo がいっぱいありますコンピューターの関係なんかそちらが多いですよ
ね
そうだこれを英語の木の根っこに持ってくればいいんじゃないかしら
思ったんですそれで例えばそれを例にとって言いますとおばあちゃんはですね
あのアパートとかデパートという言葉をよく知ってました
ん
アパートデパートと言うとボールなどね共催するとか part
者込んだパートというのを根っこにしてそれを持って海外旅行をしたらどうかしら
ということで私は出かけていったのでした
そしてまず
パートというのは別れるとか離れるとかそういう意味ですよね
でまず空港に行ったらディパーチャーゲートってのがあったんです
ここにもパートという字が入ってましたまあすごいと思っちゃいました
それからパートタイムジョブとかだんだんその
パーチペイととかあのパティキュラーとがだんだん2
井筒難しい言葉にも手が出るようになりました
そしてある時イタリアに浸らそこのガイドさんがコの字裏ワ
パルチザンが
多才だと方なんですよパズ死産
パーティーだあれこれもパートと関係があるんじゃないそうよねだったこれベス像単に
3ですもんねと思いました
そして今度ドイツに行って新聞の大きな目指しにパータイプでてたんですねあれこ
れってパーティーの骨じゃないか
者と思いました
私の
あんその英語の木には英語だけではなくて
ヨーロッパホノミまでなるようになったんですすばらしいです私は感動しました
それから
私はでもそんなことはさておき
私の教具力は本当におぼつかないものでした
で私の投資になると皆さんもあのおじいさんお父さんがお母さんかおじいさまおばあ
さまに聞いていただくと分かるんです
口のここまで出てる言葉が出てこないということで時々あるんです
今
こうやってお話せてもあるんですけどそれだけはとても依頼出します
でもそんな時どうするかと言いますと私はあのコンピュータに頼むんです
コンピュータにですねうん
フレンチデザートふわふわ
これが出るでしょうか
出ましたねここにですね優れって名前がでてきたんです
そうして
あなたの食べたいのはこれでしょって画素まで出てきたんですすばらしいです
コンピューターにできることはコンピューターにお願いすればいいんです
でもこういうのが英語ではなくて他の分野でも何か
年寄りだけが持っているシニアの特性を生かした勉強方法というのが今後を考えられ
たらいいなと思いました
そうすれば深夜が下がってガッカリすることはないんです
もしかすると80代をでは遅いではなくて橋中ではまだ間に合う
80代は素出し the 街のビザ針になるかも差はない
まあそれはちょっと楽観的過ぎるかも分からないですけれども
ただそれはいいんですしかし私はそれと同じだけの
コンピューターで答えてくれられるようなあの言葉だけではなくもっと
もう一つ大事なものがあると思ったんですそれはあのパン製造が情緒とか感動増加いう
世界です
これはこの気持ちの共有というのはコンピューターの翻訳エンジンだ
ちょっと難しい
のですでも
私たち年を取っても根崎人になってもあの
認知力がだんだん低下して
物忘れが激しくなっても
感情とが反動とかいうものは結構以来と水目指し9残ってんです
寂しいやるせないとかいうことわくわくする感動
八景しただけの喜び何かを発見した時の喜びや
たくさんあるんですね
ですからこれは今まで通りに在陣していきたい
そんな風に考えています
それからあの私はあの
を ic 定番人槽を志していますそれは情報の力で視野がより一層楽しい
内容のあるシニアライフを送れるかだと思ったんですけども
心理あの人に一緒にこういう英語の木を植えて
英語にも目覚めて一緒にそうすればもっと広い世界が私たちの前にし開けるのではない
かと思います
性に21世紀のこれかが起こるいろいろなほども
もしも受け入れられる好奇心と
タフなんマインドがあればきっと
21世紀は素晴らしいといいますのは私たち
いわゆるおばあちゃんの知恵てるのを持っていますおばあちゃんの知恵というのはあの
8話ずつ叱ってきた経験に学び
でそれがじっくり熟成させてできたものが
おばあちゃんの教えですそれ
8豊かな感性上巻
そういうものがあるしニャー活躍すれば少子高齢化の日本もすごい人材をたくさん
抱えることになると思います
それで私は私の生きてる間にできないことは次の世代に引き継いでいきたいとおもい
ます
ですから私は自分の育てている機に毎晩水をやると同時に他の皆さんにも今日植える
ことをオススメしようと思っているのです
そして気がどんどん増えて
いけばやがては森になりますそしてその森がいくつもいくつもできて海外の俺ができれ
ば地球は
溝井に囲まれた平成ニャー爆生になります
素晴らしいことですでもそれには
木に水をやって育てていかなければいけないのです
ですから私は今日もこれから
もしも私があの
明日死んじゃうということがわかっていても私は
自分の霧水をやってこうやって水をやりながら薄く死んでいきたいとおもいます
といいますのも
それが次の世代を育てるからです
リボンリーフ
うーん
アイヌ
あるボーイング2で泊まろうあいっ
ウォーター
エイブリー my tree ず
と day 3ケーブルはん